bien évidemment quand ils veulent vous
faire taire c'est jusqu'à vous tuer
c'est
bonjour je m'appelle Sergio 9 je suis
virus je suis né en 1961 à Moscou et je
suis venu en 2001 en France pour
demander l'asile politique parce que
j'étais un espion et j'ai été poursuivi
par le régime de Poutine donc je me suis
venu me cacher en France j'ai passé mon
enfance à Moscou Moscou c'est la
capitale de Russie de enfin l'URSS à
l'époque l'Union soviétique j'ai fait
mes études dans une banlieue qui
s'appelle zenograd qui était le centre
de l'industrie électronique de l'Union
soviétique et mes parents étaient
ingénieurs travaillaient dans les usines
et des instituts de recherche de cette
de cette ville c'est une ville fermée où
il y avait pas d'étrangers et donc j'ai
suivi toute ma scolarité dans cette
ville en Russie c'est de sept ans à 17
ans on fait les études dans la même
école à partir de là du primaire
jusqu'au lycée sans changer de bâtiment
ce qui est intéressant par rapport à ces
études c'est bien évidemment j'y suis
tout le site tout le cursus j'étais un
bon élève j'ai été choisi aussi par le
Parti communiste pour faire pour
travailler dans les organisations de la
Jeunesse communiste pour les encadrer ça
ça m'a ouvert après les les voies
royales pour pour la carrière dans la
diplomatie dans le commerce extérieur et
puis dans lequel GB à l'âge de 11 ans
j'ai commencé à prendre l'anglais qui
était une langue qui me plaisait
beaucoup et après une année d'études
j'ai gagné mon premier concours régional
en cette langue est-ce que je savais pas
cette époque c'est que en fait tous les
gagnants et tous les lauréats de ces de
ces petits concours qui s'appellent les
Olympiades rentré dans la batte de nez
du KGB pour servir après le base de
données pour les futurs candidats pour
l'espionnage pour partir à l'étranger en
1980 pendant les Jeux Olympiques de
Moscou j'ai travaillé comme volontaire
pendant les Jeux j'étais dans le service
de renseignement téléphonique et il y a
un Français qui m'a appelé parce qu'en
fait personne ne nous appelait toutes
les délégations avaient leurs propres
guides qui étaient d'ailleurs les agents
du KGB personne ne nous a appelé et puis
un moment donné il y a un coup de fil
qui est venu dans ce dans ce service
c'était un Français qui était juste
curieux il est tombé sur moi et on est
resté pendant deux heures à bavarder
avec lui tu as paru très suspect à mes
supérieurs qui ont appelé une KGB et on
est venu me chercher après cette
conversation m'a amené à la Lucas le
siège du KGB qui est le service de
sécurité des temps et on m'a interrogé
dans ce service concernant ce coup de
fil la personne qui m'a interrogé
s'appelait Vladimir Poutine il était
capitaine à l'époque il avait déjà 5 ans
de service en KGB il est à réquisitionné
lui aussi pour les Jeux Olympiques donc
c'est lui qui est qui m'a interrogé et
d'ailleurs là j'ai pu voir quelle
personne elle était parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui a voulu absolument me
mettre une procédure pénale très grave
sur sur les épaules parce que ça ça lui
permettait de faire un bon en carrière
parce qu'il voulait rester en fait à
Moscou et voulait rester dans la
capitale il a pas réussi et donc Poutine
qui qui m'a interrogé donc en fait sont
interrogatoire à rater mais n'empêche
que il a bien évidemment fait un dossier
c'est une fiche et mon nom est rentré
dans le radar du KGB lorsqu'on on vous
met alternative soit on vous met en
prison comme un espion indiscident soit
vous travaillez pour le KGB mais bien
évidemment vous choisissez très vite
travailler pour le KJB mais deux ans
après j'ai changé d'avis pendant toute
il y a tout un cursus de préparation
qu'il faut subir des tests il faut subir
après des déformations pratiques et
théoriques et donc au bout de deux ans
j'ai dit finalement j'ai changé d'avis
je veux pas le faire et m'ont laissé
faire donc je suis sorti de cette école
j'ai travaillé une année au ministère de
commerce extérieur mais ils étaient
quand même très malins parce que ils
m'ont pas laissé en fait tomber en
réalité ils m'ont mis dans un placard
dans une pièce où il y avait pas où il y
avait pas de fenêtre où on était 7 et on
travaillait sur les chiffres à la
longueur de la journée donc au bout
d'une semaine je commençais à devenir à
peu près fou et au bout de deux semaines
j'ai dit à mon officier traitant qui a
gardé toujours contact avec moi
excusez-moi j'ai compris que j'ai commis
quand même une faute et donc je voudrais
bien quand même revenir sur sur ma
décision si c'est possible finalement un
an après en 1984 je suis rentré dans
l'école d'espionnage qui s'appelle
l'Institut Andropov ou l'Institut de
Droit peau rouge ou encore l'école de la
forêt tout ça c'est la même chose et en
1984 quand je suis rentré dans cette
école j'ai rencontré encore une fois
Poutine parce que lui aussi la même
année il est rentré dans la même école
mais avant de rentrer dans cette école
on s'est rencontré sur un grand parking
où ils ont rassemblé toute la promotion
on s'est reconnu dans la foule avec lui
et là je lui ai dit j'ai un peu récané
en disant cette fois-ci vous voyez on se
retrouve du même côté des barricades et
ça n'a pas fait rire en réalité parce
que il y a quelque chose que moi je
connaissais pas mais lui il connaissais
c'est que ça faisait déjà vu 9 ans qu'il
était au KJB et en réalité on rentrait
dans la même école mais moi je rentrais
directement après l'université et lui il
lui a fallu 9 ans pour y arriver ça veut
dire qu'il a eu 9 ans de retard et ce
qui s'est passé encore pire dans sa
carrière c'est que après une année de
ses études à
les gens du KGB lui ont dit on veut pas
de vous dans l'espionnage parce que vous
êtes une personne imprévisible vous
pouvez prendre des décisions qui peuvent
avoir des conséquences dangereuses pour
vous-même et pour le service et donc on
vous garde pas dans le ciel des
espionnage il a été renvoyé à ingrad
donc en fait sa carrière des espions il
a raté en 1981 je suis venu à Paris
puisque je suis venu pour faire
soi-disant les reportages sur toutes les
institutions françaises importantes le
palais de l'Élysée la présidence de la
République le Premier ministre où c'est
le Matignon d'autres institutions qu'on
ne Parlement par exemple et aussi les
nains et l'École nationale
d'administration qui est basée sur
l'autorité du Premier ministre français
et qui forme l'élite française bien
évidemment cette école nous intéressait
nous quand je dis nous KGB nous nous
intéresser parce que tous les gens qui
finissent cette école finissent soit
président il y a eu quatre présidents y
compris président Macron et président
allemand Hollande
au premier ministre beaucoup de Premier
ministre beaucoup de ministres beaucoup
d'hommes
beaucoup de directeurs de grandes
entreprises françaises donc en fait
c'est les gens qui portent les secrets
comme on dit c'est les porteurs de
secrets et donc cette école qui forme
c'est élite française nous intéressait
au KGB je suis venu faire un soi-disant
un reportage sur cette école ils m'ont
reçu très gentiment et m'ont parlé de
cette école et au bout de deux heures
finalement ils ont ils m'ont dit vous
savez cette année en fait en 1991 nous
avons changé nos règles et nous
admettons maintenant des Soviétiques qui
jusqu'à maintenant n'étaient pas
admissible dans cette école et donc
est-ce que ça vous dirait de rentrer
dans notre école pour suivre le cursus
universitaire poste universitaire dans
cette école bien évidemment en tant
qu'espion c'est une réussite
extraordinaire je j'imaginais même pas
avoir ça je pensais avoir juste quelques
contacts avec eux et là elle proposait
de rentrer en fait c'est comme on
proposait un loup de rentrer dans la
bergerie et non seulement de rentrer
dans la bergerie et on m'a dit et en
plus pendant vos études on va les vous
les payer les études la France qui va
vous donner une bourse pour que vous
soyez le boursier du gouvernement
français pour faire ses études donc bien
évidemment quand je suis rentré à Moscou
à raconter ça à mes généraux ils étaient
très contents et comme ça en 1991 j'ai
commencé à suivre les études à l'ENA je
suis le premier soviétique à faire
rentrer dans le cycle long de l'ENA
l'émission d'espion ça ça dépend dans
quelle partie vous trouvez lorsque vous
êtes vous-même sur le terrain votre
travail c'est de récupérer de recruter
les sources pour avoir des informations
très importantes cachées souvent
secrètes en France et qui intéresse
votre pays votre service pour avoir ces
informations bien évidemment
contrairement au film d'espionnage vous
ne pouvez pas rentrer vous-même dans ces
dans ces bâtiments pour ouvrir les
coffre-forts pour voler des documents
tout ça c'est du cinéma dans la réalité
ça se passe pas comme ça vous devez
trouver tout simplement une personne qui
travaille déjà et essayer de la
retourner essayer de la faire trahir
pour qu'elle trahisse son pays son
service et qu'elle vous donne les
documents qui vous intéressent voilà
c'est ça c'est sa notion mais vous
pouvez faire aussi l'espionnage cosmique
vous pouvez avoir des satellites qui
vont filmer tous les pays qui vont avoir
des des images qui vous permettront
d'avoir aussi d'informations vous pouvez
aussi enregistrer tout ce qui est
enregistreble soit en vidéo soit en
audio par exemple les téléphones et pour
avoir aussi les conversations qui vous
intéressent donc l'espionnage c'est
énorme le fait de vous mettre en
opposition par rapport à votre ancien
service et de rendre publiquement
de rendre au public le fait que vous
avez été espion c'est déjà commettre en
quelque sorte une trahison par rapport à
ce service et donc du coup vous devenez
l'organique il vous aime pas ils
essaient de vous faire taire etc bien
évidemment quand ils veulent vous faire
taire c'est jusqu'à vous tuer c'est ça
peut aller très très loin après dans la
vie bien évidemment on prend aussi ses
précautions vous savez quand vous avez
été formé
même si vous vous ne voulez pas le faire
vous avez vous gardez quand même
quelques réflexes et quand on propose
d'avoir des interviews avec les
personnes que je connais pas forcément
donc là aussi je vais mes recherches je
prends des précautions quand il y a des
rendez-vous souvent je fais un petit
itinéraire de contrôle pour savoir si je
suis pas suivi si s'il n'y a pas des
personnes qui me veulent du mal autour
de moi donc ça ça reste vous avez des
réflex